our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us today
we take you across the Hudson River from
New York City to join dozens of
neighbors for a home-cooked meal each
month people in Hoboken New Jersey
gather with family and friends for a
good old-fashioned potluck dinner Don
Dahler got a seat at the table Don good
morning good morning just a ferry ride
away from New York City Hoboken New
Jersey has a diverse population of just
over 53,000 people including longtime
locals and transplants from all over the
world we got to meet some of those
residents at a neighborhood gathering
reminiscent of another time what do you
make Hoboken resident Ramona Braxton is
doing her part to cook dinner for a
hundred or so of her neighbors on the
second Monday of each month folks from
this neighborhood and Beyond have
gathered to share a meal it started two
years ago as a way to help heal after a
tragic shooting but after finding
comfort in food and community with the
dinners they decided to keep up the
tradition our let Braxton Ramona's mom
has been volunteering her time and her
daughter's since the beginning and there
was a young lady first
Julia she just wanted to community
so I said well that sounds good you know
what I'll hang in me I'll do this you
know and from that moment on I've been
stuck the only time I have you've been
stuck stuck along with John Milius I
didn't cut it straight you're right ARLA
everything Arlette says is right I'm
always wrong she told us that actually
he lives across the street from the
public housing building where the
dinners are served and has become one of
the coordinators I love the idea of
getting to know new people and just kind
of building relationships with them it's
one of my favorite things to do it's the
guide the electric family and Milius and
his fellow hosts have created quite a
family to make sure that you introduce
you to self to somebody that you maybe
you haven't met before regular guests
include local politicians business
leaders and members of the Hoboken
Police Department you're here on your
own time
we come down first pretty good too I so
much so if the food is what attracts
people hey hey is the conversation what
keeps them here I would like to think so
yeah
I mean first it's a really important
factor yeah but I think the idea of
breaking down barriers and creating
bonds with people is something that
keeps people always coming back energy
what do you think is it the food or is
it meeting the people who live around
you what's the best part this dinner has
been so well received among the
community that our let Braxton tells us
sometimes there's standing-room-only the
local high school has also started
hosting community meals as well okay I'm
hungry now
that food hurt rice and beans oh my god
yeah but not everybody's right some
because I saw that Popeyes there
somebody brings food it's totally a
community or die it takes place at a
public housing area yeah but across the
street are these trendy condos and
people come from there's no good